jeanette nguyen
hi how are you thanks for coming on the
show i'm happy to be here it's such a
fun vibe
i'm loving the atmosphere yes and i'm
super grateful to evan
bliss for introducing us thanks evan
thanks evan we love you very much
we love evan he's a fun guy you and i
have had a solid
two hours of just unpacking all things
life it's been so nice
it has been very nice i've learned a lot
about you and your
fascinating background me too about you
yeah
i'm all over the place but i love it
we're very super connectory
it's nice yeah yeah i'm really excited
to unpack we have
let's see we have a lot of topics lined
up
mainly the work in social impact
education
and especially the intersection of
entertainment and civic engagement
which i'm super looking forward to
talking to you about it's a very
important field actually
a lot of los angeles can
leverage the in the entertainment
industry for
these styles of purposes whether it be
civic engagement or like we were talking
about
enlightenment and awakening
investigating consciousness
executing the sustainable development
goals all these sort of
leverage entertainment in hollywood for
tackling these biggest
absolutely they say the world moves
forward with the story right
yes yes exactly and so leverage the
memetic
capital the story capital
to catalyze more and more of the
execution of those biggest challenges
yes
and the media power and the talent here
which is why i'm so excited that you're
having this podcast in l.a
yes what a nice breath of fresh air yes
the weather's better too
the big move i love it i love it and i
love
being in a a new nodal
cluster and exploring that because
you get saturated in terms of nodal
clusters and connections
when you have been somewhere for a long
long period of time several years and
that kind of a thing and then
so the for being having these fresh new
bonds
connecting between nodes is so fun
and just seeing where that next one goes
and how it's going to open up so many
so many epic doors and you know that's
kind of what this has been like with
with you already so far with evan and
with people like you
and we had what's up kroll on the show
and we're going to have a lot of other
uh i am already watching the branching
happening of entry into so many
different
clusters yeah it's like
it's it's so fun jeanette you
have you're not only a very colorful
person
you're you have a very colorful
background and a very colorful star
so let's go through the
journey so walk me through
who you were growing up your family
lineage
yeah also kind of like that childhood
discovery of your star
take us on the journey yeah um i guess
i'll start with my mom
so my mom was a refugee from vietnam she
came here on a boat
she uh was five days at sea in like this
rickety boat
landed in the philippines stayed there
for six months
actually was raped in the philippines
got pregnant with my brother gave birth
to him in philadelphia
and the guy was completely abusive so
one day when he was like gone or left
she told me that she had a little bit of
money
saved and she took off with my brother
to california and hid from him
met my dad um while taking english
classes
and what she loved about my dad was his
family he has a very fun colorful
family and she said she felt so alone
because she here she was
by herself in california with the baby
so she needed that stability married my
dad
that relationship didn't work because
they were polar opposites
and um had two kids with him so divorced
my dad when
i was four but you know this is how i
like to describe my dad my dad is an
excellent dad but he's an awful husband
he was very much around for me when i
was a kid doted on me was obsessed with
me was in love with me
i was like his pride and joy um
so growing up it's like it was very much
a dichotomy i felt like i lived the
double life
um my dad was very irresponsible
i think i mentioned to you earlier that
if i didn't have my mom around i'd
probably be a raging narcissist
you know i could do no wrong in his eye
i was always perfect if i
had a bad grade in school it was the
teacher's fault it was never my
responsibility
or as my mom was the complete opposite
it's like let me give you a list
of everything that's wrong with you and
what you need to improve the yin yang
yeah but my mom was also um very
hands-off kind of parenting
um you know you hear these stereotypes
of like you know asian families and like
a tiger mom my mom was not that um
partly because she was a hustler and she
was busy running her business and
she wanted to just make a lot of money
because she had
three kids at the time to feed and take
care of you know until
my stepdad came around and she had my
younger brother so there's four of us
she had quite the experience also was
this in her mid-20s
when she was making the move and she got
raped and this is
this was no she was a teenager when this
happened she was a teenager so she was
like 18.
she was like 18 when my brother was born
yeah oh
my god so i mean my mom had kids pretty
young i mean i think i mentioned to you
earlier like the only child
kid of hers who was planned was my
brother and she had him at 41.
your youngest my youngest brother yeah
and i was 17 when he was born
this is a very intense lineage
yeah but despite it all she became
an entrepreneur and like yeah that's
really interesting
she became very successful she retired
at 55.
yeah so she did well for herself
um damn she just had to you know get rid
of the
baggage that was holding her down the
trauma became the treasure
yeah um so i mean i had a great
childhood growing up in a sense that you
know my mom was
pretty hands-off because she was busy
running her business and she was a good
mom she just wasn't around that much
because she was really busy
but um so i started off
in the industry when i was 17 years old
i would say my my youth was kind of like
an uh
almost famous that movie i
seriously i was running around with a
bunch of like
these major rock stars you know i was
going through
to uh concerts left and right i was just
interviewing these rock stars and
getting paid to do it
and you know when you're in high school
and you're getting a hundred dollars an
article and you do three of them a week
and you're not paying any bills it's
like i thought i was balling and i was
rich and i got into all the parties all
the vip parties
and that was what segwayed me and gave
me a leg up
where i entered the entertainment
industry very young yeah yeah
so you're you were writing i was i mean
i wasn't a good writer
i was blogging i'd say more so blogging
yeah blogging for nam the national
association of music merchants
cool yeah and that was getting you
really well connected at a young age as
well
yeah i mean it got me internships early
on when i was still in college and
trying to figure out what i wanted to do
even though i already had an idea
so yeah it gave me the connections the
early exposure
to the point where by the time i
you know started seriously interviewing
for real jobs
out of college i wasn't really nervous
anymore because at that point i've
already spoken to you know all of my
childhood heroes
the biggest rock stars so i would go in
and it's like yeah he's the ceo whatever
yep so it i think it's made me
um a better person and it's
it made it gave me early exposure to the
world
yeah and it helped me um have a better
understanding of people
and to realize that i really love people
and being around them yeah yeah
the better that we can ask people
questions
and genuinely relate to their
journey the more that they feel
comfortable with
sharing their wisdoms yeah and we learn
so much
through those relationships and
it's no surprise to me that it's kind of
like
it's definitely like joseph in the code
of many colors of the biblical story
the you the more
the pants of many colors the hair of
many colors the shirt of many colors for
you
the many colors signify the ability to
be able to
take on all of these different
complex structures of psyche and be able
to
play with them and engage them
and swap between those costumes
and that fluidity is it's a super
powerful thing especially for super
connecting where we'll
kind of take this this next bit so
how did you end up uncovering that
what your north star was throughout this
process so this is the earlier
foundational days and
blogging and getting into entertainment
and
and you know you have your trajectory
into usc
as well but kind of like yeah walk us
through that path of
of that north star identification yeah
so i'm from huntington beach
so i'd say the early days of my career
i was running around with skaters and
punk rockers i was working at hurley
corporate
working at vans you know action sports
in music marketing at that department
you know segwayed into the agenda show
which is now this huge thing in the
fashion industry right
and then when i finally did graduate
with my undergrad
i was project manager at an
entertainment ad agency where i was
handling um national
experiential campaigns um for you know
big studios and lifestyle companies like
fox and paramount etc
but then i hated that job even though it
looked sexy on paper
just because this was the dead of the
recession and i felt like i was working
the job you know the job of three people
and being underpaid and i think my mom
was secretly happy about it because she
would say
oh you hate your job oh that's great
maybe you should go to grad school
she's always been trying to get me to go
to grad school and i just thought no i
don't really want to go to grad school
you know i was tired of school
but then it got to the point where i'm
like you know what i can use an extended
adolescence
what am i doing we're in the recession i
don't like this job let me just apply to
usc and if i get in i'll go
if i don't then i'll just find another
job right because i'm kind of doing that
anyways
i got into usc and uh i got
my graduate degree in entertainment
marketing communications management
had an amazing time there created a
startup that went viral there that
inspired an entire episode of the big
bang theory
and you know got me a lot of press and
it was an
it accidentally went viral because it
was actually um
a fake marketing plan school project
and my partner and i decided to let's
just
buy some at like fifth spend fifty
dollars we'll put something out on
twitter
we'll go to comic-con we'll beta test it
for the class it's a project right it's
a huge project it took up a lot of our
a huge chunk of our grade which is why
we took it seriously and
the next morning i get a call from fox
can we interview you it ended up being
like a one and a half minute segment and
then like
from there it was like abc
nbc cnn bbc
like followed suit so then it became a
thing so then i thought okay i guess
we'll make it into a real business i
mean it went viral screw it maybe this
is a sign
so i ran with that for a while and it
was all fun but to be honest
it just wasn't my passion it was just
this fun
thing at the time and i was still a
student and i had all these other
opportunities can you give us a quick
idea of what it was
yeah it was called line angel so it was
like the uber of not wanting to wait in
line so you could be in two places at
once and save time so a lot of our
clients were celebrities
or just movers and shakers in la you
know they wanted the latest sneakers
whether that was yeezys or like it was
people were using it for fashion um
sample sales
launches celebrity meet and greets
concerts so they could have good seating
um
yeah it was a lot of fun and the general
idea is
somebody of of a higher wealth that
wants to
not wait in line will pay somebody to
wait in line for them and then they will
go
and take the spot once you get to the
line yeah or they'll go and actually
purchase the item or if it's they're
waiting right yeah for them and stuff
like that yeah
i am proud of the fact that i created
jobs um
and it helped a lot of people that was
fun but
you solved a problem that's ultimately
what the entrepreneur
is is you found that niche solved the
problem yeah solve the problem exactly
there was a niche right and it was just
funny
how that came about but i did learn a
lot about it you know
um consumers uh i think it was like the
baseline for a lot of
uh things that i've learned about
communication and just
engaging with you know different
demographics of people that i've carried
on
to the social impact work that i did in
politics and you know
at usc through the annenberg innovation
lab
uh for the past year and a half i've
been heavily involved in
working on the census so i would say
that i'm at the intersection of
civic engagement and entertainment i
connect
hollywood to politics and vice versa
i'll work with celebrities influencers
youtubers
to help them craft the message that's
authentic to their brand
and we'll talk about civic engagement
topics such as the census and
not a lot of people know about the
census and why it's so important because
it happens every 10 years
but you know especially for communities
of color
it's funding for every person counted
it's 20
000 goes into your community over the
course of 10 years
so let's say there's a building in
koreatown and they're not being counted
that could be millions of dollars that
your community is losing
right um it also determines
congressional seating
which make up the electoral college um a
reason why
the current administration was trying to
suppress the census so much was because
they were trying to take away
congressional seats from the blue states
such as new york and california so that
we have a you know
uh a weaker vote so there was a lot as
at stake with the census and there was a
lot of misinformation
because certain groups didn't want
communities of color to be counted
because that equals power
money and representation so there was a
lot that i was doing to combat that
and i worked with some amazing um
influential
celebrities and stars like you know that
were big in the gen z space like sky
jackson who's a huge disney star and
she's on dancing with the stars now and
i think she has like
7 million followers on ig people like
that
and so this is super interesting so
there's
every 10 years it's since when did this
star was like the late 1800s right i
think so
census so this is this is important for
let's list the okay so congressional
districts yes and also
taxpayer so funding so
we pay taxes right it's like i think
it's like 800 billion dollars
that the government has like taxes so
it's like the census determines
that's where the tax money military
budget that's crazy
that's just the military budget yearly
yeah that's why 100 billion yeah it's
like four and a half trillion or
something oh my gosh
yeah and then it's like 28 trillion in
debt
i know it's very very very the numbers
are insane but
the census determines where the tax
dollars go
and it's based on population so if you
don't fill out the census if your
household doesn't fail at the census and
your community loses the funding
just 20 000 per person over 10 years
over 10 years so
schools okay so 2 000 a year
is going to schools literally in your
community in your community you're
missing 2 000
a year if you don't fill out the census
and
say that hey we had a birth of a baby
there's you know yeah
but obviously the sense has passed but
it was a big thing as you know this year
it was in the media a lot um
and hopefully people filled it out but
you know i'm just putting the
information out there that the next
10 years from now fill out your census
well the idea that we were talking about
before
we went live is that we now have the
technological infrastructure that's
getting more and more closer to star
trek
and further and further away from
chimpanzees and so we need to go
more and more towards what is
cryptography what
is leveraging the smartphones and like
this the whole idea is that you know if
i'm already born
in a hospital and i'm already accounted
for in
social security system you know there i
am in the
in the census okay now i move to a
different area i have gps location on my
on my google maps on my iphone you know
there's so many ways to register
like oh okay you know allen's now
registered in the united states postal
service at this
address you know he's been living there
three years so
you know this is where his census data
is right now
and there's so many ways to do data
fusion to enable this so we're not
sending a sheet of paper i agree
yeah but it's so antiquated the way they
do things
this is very important though like
you're that you're describing this is a
crucial statistic
two thousand bucks a year is a lot of
money
and what we're one more time on the
investments this is is this
uh is this also for things like
uh like roads and bridges roads well you
think about
covet i'll give you i'll give you an
example covid right let's say we have a
vaccine
they got to figure out where to
distribute the vaccine they also look at
census data
you know uh there's an emergency it's
like okay do we have enough shelters
there's things that they create in place
amazon wants to build a warehouse
somewhere for example
they look at census data so businesses
use it too to figure out business moves
but from a governmental perspective it's
about funding
representation and power and if you
don't fill it out you essentially give
all that away
okay yeah interesting so moving forward
in the future funding representation and
power
fused with technology can more easily
identify where people are living
yeah let's hope we get to that point
where yeah we need to architect that we
need to build
it we need to build it we need to focus
on that
yeah there's a lot of other data points
to fuse besides
uh the census data like the psychometric
data the biometric data
so you want to be able to predict a
pathology that's developing in your body
prior to it actually emerging
you know that's the the health that's
the sick care system that we go to today
and we want the health care system where
i can feel like an 18 year old
basically the rest of my life yeah peak
capacity of my body
and same thing with psychometrics you
know like
right now evan was like our machine
learning algorithm evan bliss was like
i know that jeannette nguyen and alan
sakhyan are going to relate well so i'm
going to link them up and then we do
right
yeah but based on our psychometrics
based on our levels of extroversion and
openness
and creativity and all these types of
things you know the ml algo can just
set up you and i on a facetime call for
you know three o'clock p.m on tuesday
and then you and i jump on that call
based on literally our psychometric data
and so we are we are already predicting
the fact that
we are going to vibe and we are going to
create a good amount of things together
yeah and so you know either one of us
can look into that if it doesn't look if
it looks like something that might have
been a mistake we can always decline it
and stuff like that so
yeah so there's so much to do in the
space of
especially given as important as
it is to have representation and power
and
the issue is there's groups who don't
want that so they're going to fight
against that
hence the large amounts of
misinformation that have been
going on about what it means to fill out
the census for example
no ice is going to go knock on your door
don't do it you know stuff like that
which is why
it was such an issue and why it was
actually a really tough campaign
because of all the bots and the
misinformation about trying to scare
people to not be counted
similar to voter suppression wow there's
a lot of
parallels and that's something i've been
trying to combat too
you know especially with the last
election was a lot of voter suppression
work
it's really creating targeted pieces of
media
aimed towards very specific communities
to get them to vote
and that was something i did in politics
gosh i probably produced
over 20 psas within the last
year you know about the census and about
voting
wow yeah so
maybe walk us through what it looks like
for a team to create
a psa and a public service announcement
and where did you know where does the
funding come from for the team
you know how does the team work together
[Music]
what platforms does it disseminate how
do you leverage the influencers for more
reach
yeah yeah well the census psas we got a
grant from the gates foundation
okay thanks bill gates bill and melinda
yep
they're like they're in a lot of
interesting
places they really are yeah they're
omnipresent
they're everywhere yeah and also just
for those that
you know that really tend to kind of
jump into like a binary thought process
about
people like bill gates or jeff bezos and
melinda gates and
and rock star
sort of you know billionaire fortune 500
people that everyone's a mix of
there's good and bad in all of us and
that it's not a binary thing
it's just so quickly that people jump to
sort of binary like
this person is evil this person is good
and like that's the way that i see the
world and it's like
no we're mixes of both we all have
shadows we all have gifts we have to do
our best to work on integrating the
shadows
but also people just like all like for
example i know so many people
that have never even uh
researched the depths of like the bill
and melinda gates foundation's
impacts across the planet in terms of
actualizing the sustainable development
goals and then they'll have a binary
perspective about it being
horrible based off tabloid gossip
tabloid gossip stuff yeah because that's
the stuff that people remember and
that's the juicy stuff
you know people gravitate towards bad
news people don't want to
do the work which is you know like bill
and melinda gates would do something
like
analyze the amount of people on the
planet that are using
pit latrines yeah and that you know
because
here we're hedonically adapted to being
able to open up the
tap and get water and to go to the
bathroom and flush our
our toilet and completely not care about
any of the wastewater treatment that has
to happen
and that in other places in the world a
billion people across the planet
still having to you know go in
and use these holes that are dug up in
the ground to go
and and urinate and poo in and that then
you get the flies that go and land on
that and then fly back over on the food
sources
then you eat those you get diarrhea and
that you die
and that there's just all of this sort
of it's all
it's all you have to look for it you
have to look for the
the patterns in how to optimize the
basic needs being met of people around
the planet so that they can bring their
gifts forward
and that's what i think i think people
in a sense i think people
they don't want to do the hard work
yeah of analyzing that that pattern and
and like like and like also admitting
that other people that are smarter than
them
have went and have that have more
resources and that have analyzed those
patterns
that that they have went and done that
process and people sometimes just don't
want to
like say that like that is happening so
they go off that tabloid gossip
little tangent but i wanted to say that
because it's important they funded the
psas
and that the the census psas and that
there's just
it is very very important like people
will look at jeff yeah
bezos and they won't even take into
account the fact that like
20 years ago the guy was literally
driving packages
himself to the post office to ship and
that he was hoping to one day buy a
forklift
like this is his story you know this is
literally his story right and that
you know now there's investments into
blue origin for spaces investments into
uh nuclear fusion industry as well for
clean and sustainable sources of energy
abundant
sources of energy for us and so it's
it's like get away from binary
one-dimensional thinking and dive into
the depths of these
of people at their most complex you know
whether it be somebody just like you and
i or whether it be somebody that is
in a position of having a billion
dollars in a position right analyze how
they got there if it was ethical all
these types of things are important but
all right just wanted to yeah it was so
important girl it was
i'm glad you made that point yeah and
the issue is we live in an on-demand
culture where people like to be
spoon-fed information
so most people just aren't gonna dig you
know and i think part of the reason is
the way
society is constructed where most people
are
literally on a hamster wheel just trying
to survive
especially nowadays so it's a form of
privilege even to be able to sit down
and research and do deep dives right
when you don't have when you're not on
survival mode people are just on a
hamster wheel
so uh i think uh until the foundation
of that is fixed we're going to have
this issue in society
interesting so i i like your perspective
there we'll get to the psa
just that the idea is that
the more that you're on a
hamster wheel the less you're able to
research the multi-variability
in the complexity of the nuance of all
these subjects and try and
find the pattern out of all of those
variables rather than being just because
you're on the hamster wheel spoon fed
one
article retweeting or whatever exactly
the quick bites of information the
sensationalism right
so it's like you need to have the time
to research
but better than that it's like do you
even know how to effectively
research yeah right do you even have the
educational background to do that
and a lot of people don't a lot of
people don't know how to vet
misinformation from quality authentic
information
right they don't know what to look for
they don't know what's a viable source
hence why
we're in the mess that we are now
um there's just a lot of foundational
things
that completely need to be fixed you
know you could tell someone oh you know
if you only you just did your research
but
where do they have the time to do the
research when they are constantly
working and they have three kids they
have to raise and
a life that they want to live and they
need me time too and
right and this is average families
i'd say across the board most people do
not have the time or the mental space
and we were talking a lot before we
started about the
enabling the architectures the inclusive
stakeholding
all these different protocols that
biomimic the mycorrhizal networks
and that in doing so what you do is you
meet the basic needs so that people
aren't on the hamster wheels as much
and so they can then do things like
learn
upskill and so that they can learn how
to do
the phenomenon of researching from
multiple
sources and trying to find synthesis
right so it's it's it's a it's a lot
more
i don't know if there's actually
anything that's as important as
meeting the basic needs and then
upskilling people to be able to
see the complexity in the patterns that
exist
because that will enable a more robust
social fabric democracy all of those
things
and
let's go let's go through let's go
through the so there's a grant
from the billion millimeters that went
through the usc annaberg innovation lab
okay so that funded a lot of our pretty
much all of our census work no it was
that the macarthur foundation
okay um funded our census work
so that's what i was doing on the census
side
and then a lot of the um election
and voting work that i was doing we're
going to break down a psa
as well the psas are we going to break
down we could break down the psa
just curious like how many people were
on like the psa team
like it's kind of interesting to me to
like know
you know you got an influencer you
drafted some sort of a campaign
you know you put 20 of them out well not
at the same time
at different times yes yes yes um so you
know i have a background in hollywood
used to being around talent and
celebrities so i know how to communicate
to management and pr
right so i was able to get you know
pretty big stars involved
uh pro bono because they knew that it
was a great cause and
it also aligned with their brand and
their vision of where their career was
going
so you know celebrities and the
youtubers i got were activisms
or activists and they cared about
activism and social good
so usually what happens is um
okay we have this idea we want to do
psas right then you get the script
so we get writers we try to get people
in the space
who know about for example census know
about voting
um and then we sometimes it's like a
collaboration between
experts and writers and you know feeding
them information and they they try to
write something
quick concise clever entertaining i i
then i start casting
okay i do the cast things right and you
know and i'm mindful of like
representation and
all that great stuff um i'm not a
professional caster
or casting agent but i've done it a
bunch and
uh yeah and then it's like you know
certain people from my team will pull
together the technicalities of it like
who's gonna
handle the editing and the production
and the director and all of that and
it's just like a team you know
like like a little mini hollywood yeah
that goes on there's a lot of moving
parts we all kind of focus on what we
need to do and we make it happen
and then after that you know there's
distribution that's a whole nother beast
right yes and then it's figuring out
distribution and
you know luckily uh we have a lot of
community partners
and educational institutions already
intact through the usc annenberg
innovation lab
you know our brand name recognition
and who we are in the um community helps
to amplify you know those messages and
hence why we also use celebrities with
big followings because they have an
audience too
and it kind of spiral spiral and goes
from there
and it grows yeah yeah like how you
describe it as a mini hollywood yeah
it's a
good way to put it yeah it's like a mini
hollywood it's not like a blockbuster
but it's like a core team everyone has
their part
and we make magic happen with a much
limited budget yeah
yeah that was that was a really cool
breakdown
okay and then you were going into
another
subject as well when i asked you to do
the yeah i mean the psas and then i was
doing a lot of work with uh the election
and trying to rally people to get them
excited about voting i did a huge
event in hollywood i think it was back
pretty
it was like a month before shutdown of
the people this is also with you
usc no this is through a different
institution
that i met while doing a lot of work
with the census
okay um where i was working for a bunch
of politicos
okay like people you know pretty high up
there in the political space
and they needed my help and we started
doing community events and we you know
we had politicians
show up local politicians um just ex
local activists celebrities
and we threw a massive party you know
food and beverages and alcohol
everything was taken care of
uh and we registered people to vote on
site we educated them
about it we had um
who did we have fiona ma i think
california treasurer was there
we had um mitchell farrell
uh yes some local politicians there was
a bunch i don't remember and there was
all these judges
who were there um so registering people
to vote is the
core part of the host of producing these
events yeah the core part
now i don't have a background in
politics my background's more so in
entertainment
so and i think it's helped me because
i'm not
coming at everything through a political
language all the time
yes yes yes you're bringing more
innovation and strategy
yeah and i feel that way so you know
oftentimes i'm around these
bigwig judges and politicians and i
don't really
you know know like everything about them
oh yeah so it helps yeah it makes it
more fun and exciting for me too
yeah i feel like then you're learning
from one another yeah
exactly uh yeah i was doing a lot of
events to get people to vote
producing psas oh gosh there was so much
that i was doing i was traveling on the
biden campaign
i was precinct captain for uh biden
in iowa and in nevada won every precinct
that i led
and aisle was crazy the fact that we won
that was
insane but his administration really
liked me because i was able to win these
precincts you know
and so uh because of that i kept having
more opportunities
to do some more work with the biden
campaign and i was in miami
canvassing and helping with this big
voter latino event
so we have some images that i'm going to
pull up as well
and so we have
it's what what's the title again called
of the position it's a
like a precinct leader precinct captain
precinct captain
yeah okay okay so i was doing that and
so
now this is like
the idea is that once you kind of
identify
with whatever you know
i i personally really like right now
what's going on with like
the uh the independent national union
right so i really like the idea of like
what's happening with the independent
scene right now and trying to like grab
the
best from both uh conservatives and
liberals and bring those up together
into one
but so what happens then is once you
pick kind of who you really
um like like if you do like the inu and
stuff like that
your ideas is that you can get involved
and become a precinct captain for them
and then you basically go and travel to
the swing states
mostly are the important ones right now
and that
you're going and traveling and you're
trying to basically educate about the
principles that
the people that you're that are will be
that they will be voting for represent
and so that's the ideas as you go to the
different locations is that you're doing
you're kind of doing the work you're
trying to basically replicate in a sense
the ethos or ideas the memes of
the people so it's like kind of like
trying to clone
as much of the ideas as possible and
that's kind of what maybe a precinct
captain could be thought of as yeah okay
okay interesting and so so iowa was
the first place isle was the first place
they were very racist there i didn't
have a good time and it was cold
but i did what i needed to do and i won
so i was happy about that
yeah interesting yeah that's well that's
that's really close to
my uh because i'm i'm from south dakota
and so um look at all those great photos
let's see oh there i am all right so
we have some pictures to show you i'm
actually in the latest issue of time
magazine with biden there's this picture
there's this huge um
spread of him hugging this politician
and you clearly see me in the background
too
so that's you inviting yeah you were you
said you were in a
i'm in time i'm in the recent time yeah
my boss sent it to me and said you're in
time magazine i said what and she sent
me a photo of it which i thought was
funny
wow i have to i have yet to pick up the
physical issue
that's uh with the press in iowa
do you remember how much of a [ __ ] show
iowa was because they couldn't figure
out
uh who won and it was so messy that
controversy because like i guess
the app that was supposed to keep score
was completely messed up and it became
like this democratic embarrassment
i always insane it was a great
experience again we
we spent a couple of minutes talking
about this earlier but
you know we kind of have to get away
from you know sheets of paper
and you know feeding those into you know
a machine
and like that's a new invention you know
used to not you didn't even
have the machine in the passes they
tried to go
high-tech and it was a huge mess up well
we
we need a lot of features we need to fix
it yeah yeah improve it that's what it
is
yeah yeah and and we're gaining the
abilities
to do so as we're talking about things
like inclusive stakeholding
we actually have the decentralization
protocols that enable the tokenomics of
the subjects that we were talking about
earlier
but the same thing's true with applied
cryptography for voting as well we now
have
the proper protocols that enable you to
leverage the simple process of using the
devices in a very in a way that's
even more secure than the
existing so here's the thing you know um
the democrats would love to make voting
more easily
and more accessible but like i said
there's a huge portion of the population
who are trying to suppress the vote
consistently
um and that's the type of battle that
i've been dealing with with this type of
work
as long as long as it's in the ideas
that is just
a lot of what i've also understood about
what potentially a
conservative mind person would say about
is that they just wanna to make sure
that it's it's
that it's safe and that it's properly
being executed
and that you know and that that's also
like it's really actually very
psychometrically aligned
like the liberal higher openness
and the conservative sort of
conscientiousness in ensuring that it's
done in a way that is systematically
going to you know procedurally done
through like the nsa and just
done in a way that sort of has ensured
that there's not
a specific political agenda behind it
but that it leaves it open
for the actual democratic party i would
agree with that
definitely but there is a large portion
who are to be honest with you i'm going
to be flat out
just freaking racist yeah so they just
don't want people to color it about
older yeah on the i know yeah we i mean
that's the other issue
we talked about this i mean we pulled we
pulled these up
and i mean this is this is this this is
where you know we could
try and simplify this as much as
possible but you know ultimately it
really does
boil down to things you know just like
in high level perception and
in chapter four called portals it really
does boil down to simple things like
people
on this like left side of the bell curve
that are
you know really just
experiencing states of consciousness
that are still a little bit more archaic
things that are a little bit more uh you
know
racist or bigoted or xenophobic um
and also that
are like you'd be surprised at how often
you have somebody from you know where
i'm from in south dakota
where as you were saying in iowa a
little bit earlier you know
it's like they haven't left the state
they don't have a friend that is
that is black or that's latin american
or that's asian
or that's from the middle east and so
when that happens like there's
it's only propaganda from television
that that is being inserted into the
mind
and then facebook and stuff like that
yeah and from social media yeah
especially facebook so in in general the
the i
in general the idea of portals is that
you basically want to
you want to move people further and
further up the bell curve to thinking in
a way that is more
and more multivariate more and more
as a genius visionary as an entrepreneur
as an artist as a leader
as someone that's able to calculate as
many of the variables as possible
someone that's able to shoot a portal
like a code
update into the center of the pacer like
you have to become in a sense
an entrepreneur or an artist and deploy
some sort of a project into the world
that helps people
right that's why the you know you like
really like such a massive
thing that that that we have to do in
the process is
we have to do this sort of you have to
do the process of uplifting
people along the journey this isn't to
say you know
we we talked about this for a couple
minutes earlier but we have to help
the labor force upskilling process we
have to extend the hand out
and help people come through like you
can't just say that somebody is old
consciousness
and they need to die like let the you
know
at the same time the 80 year old old
white guy in the country club that
is still has experiences of not liking
black people or asian people or
middle eastern people or latin americans
is dying anyway
but there are people that are maybe 40
or 30
that have one friend that is black or
latin american whatever
and that they're becoming more open you
know they're becoming
they're realizing that maybe i should
understand what it means to have
friends of from other places in the
world and what that would mean for my
overall perspective
and we need to uplift and help in that
process i i absolutely agree you know
but deeper than that
i think that i mean if you look at the
these stats it's like i think what is it
like 54
of white women voted for trump so these
are women
who were crying about ginsburg dying
had a black square on their ig you know
what i mean
in solitary you know with uh black lives
matter
but they're gonna vote what they feel is
gonna be in their best interests and i
think it's the uphold white supremacy
i think a lot of times because i know
people and i actually have friends
who voted for trump who we got
you know kind of in at it because you
know i'm on the biden campaign right
who are very nice people have friends
of all different cultures but at the end
of the day they want to maintain white
supremacy
because they feel like it benefits them
and i think it's like the selfish type
of mentality
so what's very complicated alan
it's i i have i have i definitely have
some
points of of deep agreeance with that i
i
you know and the way that i came to
these ideas is
literally through the study of
consciousness you know i
i really take this from a pattern
recognition perspective
about the entirety of the whole reality
that we're a part of and what we're
undergoing it's a very
deeply evolutionary process and it is
consciousness as the fundamental unit
that we're talking about in this
evolution so
i do recognize and understand the things
that are being
voiced about these old ideas and these
old
codes that are dying yeah and that are
being archived in that
but at the same time that there is also
simultaneously a process of people that
are
that are you know there there is that
arm that's kind of reaching up or
there's like that pull-up that's about
to happen to that like next
like lit level of perception and that
all we need is that that that little
meme
or that little bump that little
friendship with
someone that is from a different walk of
life
and that little tiny thing upgrades
somebody to a new
way of seeing things i remember my
this is this is you know i love
experiential stories because they they
also really get this it takes
the abstract philosophical pattern level
is really important but so is the
grounded one in the flesh
in the in the body experientially i
remember after i went from sioux falls
south dakota where i grew up from zero
to 17 to minneapolis minnesota
right so minneapolis minnesota is a
massive step in like the liberal melting
pot
culturally directly you have that great
mall and i've been talking about
america you know the moment of course of
course that's the only place i've ever
gone through there i had a layover
yeah yeah you're like i have to go to
the mall of america i went to the mall
where
are my top pieces of fashion for me to
look at here go get guccifer
yeah yeah um and
that was a massive perceptual
augmentation because i
literally had on my dorm floor at the
university of minnesota
i i had latin american friends i had
black friends i had friends from so many
different unique walks of life
on my floor and it was that's exactly
that's exactly what i needed in order
for me to
realize the truth of
the love and the familial roots and the
basic needs of
of water food shelter electricity
education healthcare
these basic needs every seed needs
the basic nutrients as a tree or as a
human to
to blossom fruits and that we come from
the uniqueness of you know i didn't
really get this one until 10 years later
10 years later i started understanding
this about 28 years old i started really
getting that
consciousness is a lot like calculus
in the sense of the integral
the integration of 8 billion
perspectives 8 billion infinitesimal
data points
integrated into a unity style
perspective about what we're undergoing
as a reality
and at the same time seeing that
genetically
as our 99.9
dna similarity as humans
and then the derivative the
differentiation in calculus
is how the
the individual the seed the seeds get
the basic need nutrients
but the gifts the artistic contributions
are different yeah i host the show i
interview people
there are other people that do so many
different kinds
of of beautiful contributory gifts
and that on a genetic perspective
is 0.1 percent dna difference
yes and so this sort of you know i
didn't have that when i was 18. if i had
that when i was 18 i could have more
quickly ramped myself up and that's what
i'm trying to do for myself that's
really what we
kind of try and do for we're basically
trying to say
we're trying to be the mentor that we
never had
yeah in our own space in our own way
exactly without even realizing it
sometimes
it's very subconscious right and i think
as human beings like there is this
innate
need to give and to influence and to do
good
yes um
and hopefully you know we can
yeah i i'm i'm really kind of
i'm really bullish on taking this from a
perspective of
of consciousness because if we
if we identify sort of on that kind of
we were talking about a very like
psychometric
level of of like a conservative and a
liberal in the united states or as
somebody that
has a friend that is from a different
walk of life versus that doesn't
we can kind of begin understanding on a
data level
what's going on in people's world views
and then where they're at on this
consciousness evolutionary trajectory
right and if and this is the thing is
that the more
that we identify where people are at
we've actually
visualized the data and it's not
speculative anymore
and this is why the the ad targeting is
so
successful is because you visualize the
psychometric data
absolutely you know the demographics you
know the psychometrics you know their
ocean scores and personality traits
and so you know with a couple hundred
likes you can know someone better than
their spouse yeah and this is some this
is really interesting when
you can potentially leverage that data
for
awakening for enlightenment for
why don't we introduce you to one of the
planetary mystic traditions or why don't
we introduce you to
somebody that is studying
cryptocurrencies or blockchain
technologies or biotech or neurotech
because maybe if you get a little
trigger point into how beautiful
you know you had that picture of the
cell
uh earlier oh that i sent you it's the
latest
model of a cell yeah it's a really
it's a such a good picture let me let me
get it up for us
i was telling alan how i wanted it as a
print on a dress
how beautiful would it be with some
shiny sequin and
you know beating so runway ready
yes yes that's right so we both want to
see
put this on clothing we will co-create
that yeah
it would be fun and that the more
you know the more that we put this on a
piece of clothing and the more that
people walk around
and that ask gets stopped and asked hey
what is that
and then the other person responds and
says it's the inner life of the cell
and then that other person goes wait
what
and then there's a conversation that
struck up about how beautiful it is it
was i was telling you that it was david
balinsky's for the first one
that introduced me to the beauty of
doing the illustration
and animation of what the inner life of
the cell looked like
and then he inspired millions of people
around the world that saw that
precious video it's called the inner
life of the cell everyone that wants to
look it up and that look at how much
further though because you saw the
quality of those animations and stuff
it we're getting to a level where you
can actually
see like
we're beginning to color code and tag
parts of the cell
at the level of what are called
nucleotides or sugars or lipids and
amino acids
and these sort of proteins were
really getting down to a super
high resolution level that is hopefully
um
we can leverage this to like imagine if
we took this
and started putting this into the the
twitter and the facebook and
and the instagram feeds as something
that was like
this is inside your cells like
this is what makes you run and operate
you know yeah
and i mean we could create a whole
narrative and campaign
around that that makes it exciting
and connects with people on a deeper
molecular level
no pun intended yeah because i'm already
in my head i'm thinking oh it would be a
really cool campaign
and we can incorporate all of this crazy
technology
and um vr into like the runway show but
i'm just going off on a tangent right
now i love that
i'm a creative so yeah me too i'm all
i'm all about this kind of stuff and
though the scientific communities
especially the cycom communities
that you know a lot of my lineage comes
kind of from the carl sagan and neil
degrasse tyson that i was talking
telling you about a little bit
before we started and the intention
is to really package in as much of an
explain like i'm five ability
the profound beauty of what's actually
in the scientific realm like this and
then we can leverage the entertainment
this is exactly what we started the
conversation off with on the show
yeah you can leverage the memetic
capacities
of the entertainment sector here to do
that yeah
we can get the tick tock influencers
that become
so in awe about we have to tell the
story to them
that makes them excited about the inner
life
but then they have to understand how to
communicate it to their own language to
speak to their
audience because we want to get it to
the masses i mentioned earlier i was
working on the census that's not a cool
topic
it's really boring how do i make it
exciting how do i explain it to people
so that they understand i have to
communicate to the masses
about that right so it like it that's
another layer that i have to think about
i can't i can't explain the census to
someone
uh like a colleague you know who i went
to grad school with
i have to talk to you know that that 19
year old
in the inner city who has influence with
you know in their household who can tell
their mom or their dad hey fill out the
senses this is why it's important
so there's all these other layers um
that i have to think about when it comes
to communicating
and what that means and like how to
write
yeah and actually the most successful
creative campaigns in los
angeles are usually the ones where the
the one that the brand that's that's
doing a partnership with the with the
content creator
they give the content creator full
creative capacity absolutely that's
that's
that's the most success that you can
experience it's all about the
authenticity
yeah and this and i i also like using
sri aurobindo and the mother
they call it soul angle you let the
content creator add their
soul angle to what the
dissemination is of what the brand is is
is aiming at achieving
and when they do that then it's
authentic and that's them
so we will do this you guys you will see
more and more of this style of
of leveraging the entertainment industry
here
uh jeanette allen will be working more
and more to get
uh hollywood to in a sense
marry the profundity of science and
of uh enlightenment and awakening and
consciousness evolution and these types
of things so
um let's let's go we have we have some
more i want to showcase some more
there's a
there's a lot of them in here but let's
um because
i don't think enough people actually get
to go through this process of looking at
what it's like to
be a a pre a precinct captain um
it was a lot of work yeah yeah so iowa
you guys
did iowa we did iowa we did nevada
okay yep that's what the state we
campaigned in
um florida that's right you were in
miami but i was also doing some get out
the vote stuff
in l.a let's see okay let's see we'll
keep
we'll we'll flip through some more well
that was something i did i was a speaker
this was during the height of coven
for um i think it was nbc universal
okay i think yeah i was uh
visiting on behalf of the usc annenberg
innovation lab
so that was just a flyer that i was a
feature learn about the 2020 con
census and how to make your voice come
yeah i was educating employees about
that so i did that a few times i
i also you know oh for the microsoft
teams webinar
right yeah yeah exactly i'm like we're
trying to remember what was that
like i've done this i've done a lot of
uh speaker engagement work
so i've done that for fox and some other
companies as well yeah
media companies yeah interesting
that was um outside of a rally in nevada
for the biden campaign that particular
shot
yeah yeah there you go just see your
heads in the front yeah yeah and i
loved it just because uh there was a
rainbow in the background and i saw it
as oh i think this is the positive sign
i think he's gonna win
and it's not loading we'll see
oh technology sometimes that happens
we're coming fam
yeah we're coming hold up
oh that that was miami it was very very
hot and humid that day
again look at that outfit isn't that fun
super unique the whole thing is vintage
almost
wow it was miami i had to be fun and
colorful it was a party yeah a very
festive city i love miami
that was at the biden campaign office in
nevada
okay i remember that really well yeah
it's so interesting again that these
like these precinct captains are
are like the the mimetic like
arm and like clones of of the
of the reach i just i find that to be so
interesting
that was on set of one of the psas
we were filming during covets hence the
mass and the strict sag
protocol
oh that's sky jackson she's a huge
disney star teenagers love her
she's sassy she's fun
huge star she local
um i think so i think i mean she lives
in l.a
she's on dancing with the stars now we
should get skye on the show
i want to get to this younger
consciousness and get them to think
about what the nature of reality is
excited that was a dnc event you could
see garcetti in the background
right next to my head mm-hmm
yeah i mean there's quite a few photos
you know i i like to document things
because i like to send my mother photos
yeah mom mom's uh moms are big fans of
seeing what they love photos yeah when i
send her
what my kid is doing oh that was uh i
was um
with lausd and we were
learning i think it was like a workshop
on how to we were trying to teach
teachers how to teach the senses to
their students ah that's what it was
interesting
so more again of the teaching other
people about the census so they can
teach other people yes
it's such an interesting way to view
memes it's so
interesting that was on set of a psa
ah i see so this is what the set looks
like to
where you guys the little mini hollywood
of got it yeah that's one of them
definitely okay okay
so that was an event i did uh on behalf
of the lgbtq community
urban outfitters donated their
event space to us and it just became
this big party we had performers
we had incredible artists so so urban
outfitters got
involved with the census project as well
they were happy to give me a platform to
talk about the census
okay yeah so they but they got involved
by giving you a space yeah okay cool a
space and they supported the
marketing and the outreach that was with
pelosi
it was a brunch in briefing that that
was oc
that was in brentwood um it was at the
home of uh the founder
or the creator of the despicable me
franchise oh interesting
yeah um that was a lot of fun
because i can't i had no sleep that
night i actually came from usc
teaching a saturday workshop to high
school students
no junior high and high school students
but the night before
i think i had like three hours of sleep
because i was at this insane party on
the hollywood hills of all these
politicians
so it was like one after another um i
just remember being dead tired in that
photo but i didn't look tired
yeah yeah you kept it together i kept it
together you did
definitely oh and then i had my birthday
party after that
that's that's a pretty interesting
series of events yeah
yeah yeah that's cool that was also on
set we did this whole media press blitz
thing called vote house
where um there's a studio who my friends
own
in downtown atlanta it's gorgeous it's
called tuxedo
and we had just celebrities and
influencers and all the who's who
in the industry and politicians they
came we talked about the importance of
voting
we just created bite-sized content and
just distributed it on social media
to get people really excited about
voting like a week prior to it actually
happening
yeah so that was a huge media event that
last photo yep
yep so i'm looking at it i'm like oh
i've done all these things
i completely forgot about it's a good
thing i took photos
yeah it's also it's also good to get
into the positions where
instead of being behind a screen and
sort of trying to analyze what the life
of
uh donald trump or joe biden or nancy
pelosi
or uh mark zuckerberg or jeff bezos elon
musk or
whoever the the people are that you're
that you're talking about is to actually
achieve
enough in your life to where you get the
opportunity to actually engage with them
in person
and then make an a cl an
uneducated
experience of an in-person relationship
for you to gain that data point yeah and
i'm glad you mentioned that because like
there's a lot of things about biden that
i think are inaccurate like they say
things like oh he's sleepy joe or he
like has a bad memory
that's not true he's really really sharp
look he has a stutter and he gets
nervous when he talks in front of that
many people
so sometimes he forgets and he said he's
literally nervous
he doesn't tell you that but he's
nervous you know but look he knows
foreign policy
better than anybody he's really sharp
one-on-one
um he has a spectacular very intelligent
team and i think part of quality
leadership
is knowing you know who to vet to be on
your team
so i mean it was after that experience
where i'm like okay i'll support him
because i was iffy you know i'll admit
like i wasn't sure if that was like the
best candidate but
after that experience you know i'm
definitely team biden harris for sure
yeah to to me
there's no clearer solution than
what i outline in
the sorting algorithm
which is chapter 7 of high level
perception
i mean this is by far the only
solution that i see because there's
there's
nothing better than taking the best
possible codes
from conservatives taking the best
possible codes from
liberals and synthesizing them
into a unity and
and drain the dirty bath water as well
because there is dirty bath water
there's perverse incentives and there's
on both sides on both sides yeah they're
both sides both
good and bad exactly exactly but
sometimes
one side has more bad than others but
there is good in battle
yes and another one to put into the same
style framework is you know hollywood
and silicon valley we have our dirty
bath
waters that need to be drained but we
also have um you know california's the
sixth largest economy in the world
fifth actually we moved up as a state
yeah and that would mean we
beat the uk oh yeah yeah they're fifth
yeah well we're fifth now yeah you so
it'd be uk five
germany for japan three
china two usa one and so that's
interesting that we beat
the uk yeah so it's a little probably a
little more than
three three probably three point three
or so trillion dollars or something like
that
i think look at you yeah that's because
in fact yeah those
yeah these statistics i got i got
familiar with them uh
like yeah that that's that's an
important one to be to understand
because
you kind of want to know
where people are living and how they're
contributing to the
economies of the planet and there's
many statistics that we need to analyze
beyond gdp but that's
that's that's definitely an important
one uh like enlightenment and human
flourishing human well-being these types
of statistics
happiness joy bliss basic needs being
met this type of stuff
but another one in this is the usa and
china you need to take the good things
from the usa the good things from china
and synthesize them into a single one
drain the dirty bath water
another one is indigeneity and modernity
you can put those in the equation
you can put science and spirituality
into the equation
you know science has perverse incentives
spirituality has
dogmas and fundamentalism but science
has the beautiful
scientific method and spirituality has
the beautiful
manifestations of the divine and if you
put those two things together
you know a scientist will tell you that
when they when they found
and colored that inner life of the cell
that way that's divine
that's a beautiful just truth
good beauty divinity right there
and then the same thing's true about
spirituality when the spiritual person
learns that
that their 20 000 breasts that they take
a day come from
the photosynthesis of phytoplankton and
trees that's gorgeously
yeah synthetic between the two i love
how you explain that
so beautifully put yeah it's like this
thank you that's
i think balance is so important and i
think we do live in a world where
people forget that and it's always black
or white
that way is wrong my way is right when
really it's much more complicated than
that and i've said it before i think
the ex an extreme isn't good
there needs to be a balance yeah
yeah this is the type of perception that
when you begin viewing it from the
perspective of
trying to synthesize the good codes from
the two that you're analyzing and
draining the dirty
bath water codes it really does
drive a more higher level perception
and less of a binary one it's extremely
beautiful um
i want to hit a couple
other thoughts here with you you've
you've spent uh
a good amount of time uh with the usc
annenberg innovation lab i wanna know
what else is the annenberg and
innovation lab
really well known for what should people
know about them they're always working
on all these insane
crazy innovative projects i don't even
know what's going on
most of the time because there's just so
many different things going on
it's like this hub it's like a little
city where people are doing all these
different things
um i wasn't at the annenberg innovation
lab
every day so i don't know i was working
everywhere
so i didn't really see what other people
are working on
but like i'll get emails and i'll kind
of get like a synopsis of what's going
on and
i mean it varies and it varies you know
each semester
with a cohort or they have cohorts every
semester i think they do
i mean i know that they help students
with like their different startups and
various
uh projects but they also do a lot of
work
in the community now i was working with
the annenberg innovation lab not as a
student as like an actual yeah you know
are they doing things like entering into
mixed reality for sure
oh definitely all that they've been
doing this is the kind of interesting
stuff because
you know the berkeley college of music
over in boston yeah
they're really interesting because
they're also trying to you know blend
music production with so many different
fields and i think
annenberg innovation labs specifically
by
blending together different fields is
going to learn
that it's you can increase the
memetic efficacy at which you
disseminate content by
doing that blending process yeah and i
mean
usc is doing some amazing innovative
work i had a friend who i think she was
part of the the
showa foundation or something like that
where she was archiving
um holocaust survivors in a 3d form
because a lot of them are so old so once
they pass it's like
you can and they interact you can still
talk to them
yeah and broadcast them so they look
like they're in front of you
yeah if we did that to every single one
of the 100 billion people that has lived
and died before us today that would be
crazy to have
like a genealogical lineage of every
person that's ever lived
right their movements how they sound you
can talk to them you can talk to them
yeah they're
explaining their story oh yeah and it's
something that they're doing
to um preserve history
yes this type of stuff i'm all about i
love genealogical anthropology and
archaeology so
annenberg is that's that's interesting
what initiative is that
do you know what this is through a
different usc initiative
usc's got so much stuff going on so okay
so that's another one of our
things that we have to do is get the usc
peeps to
come on yeah and talk about all this
stuff there's amazing work that they're
doing i mean i'm a very proud trojan
i had a lot of fun at usc i met a lot of
incredible people
had a fantastic professors so yeah
i feel a a great connection to them
yeah and it's it's great because in the
silicon valley we had berkeley and
stanford as kind of our major
uh sources for a lot of the uh professor
style brilliance in here we're going to
have usc ucla
yeah there's a lot of other caltech
there's jpl
yeah lab yeah yeah uc irvine there's a
lot of great places here as well
and a lot more in the bay area that i
didn't list as well ucsf
but like like we got to get
the the those collegiate peeps onto the
program as well so let's
we'll hone in on that now
unpack for us west hollywood
weho is that right i love weho it's like
my spot
weho it's such a funny four letters
yeah it's great i mean i spent a lot of
time in great dining great shopping
fabulous people yeah see i'm not i'm not
as familiar so walk us through
um your love for west hollywood that's
what we ho means
and then also you want to run for
mayor at some point yeah i'm sure later
down the road
which is exciting not anytime soon i
mean i think i'm totally qualified to do
it
um i'd be great at it
i love that it's rotational so i have
support
you know i don't need to be you know
queen bee
all the time i think it's good to
collaborate and have different
perspectives
but i love weho you know i think part of
it is um i've always been
a huge advocate for the lgbtq community
you know i was very close to my
uncles growing up um you know
i'd say most of my friends are either
gay men or fabulous older women and
you know they really took me under their
wing and so
you know this was something that they
brought up i think you should totally
run for mayor one day it'd be so cool
jeanette and i thought oh that's cute
hahaha
but you know as i've gotten older it
kind of became like oh it's actually
possible to think i mean i have the
background for it i have the love for it
i mean i care about the community
um i'm always doing whatever i can
to help them you know
thrive to help with their rights like
whatever i can to do to help you know
i've
helped thrown um a lot of events on
their behalf to raise money for lgbtq
causes i've you know volunteered at a
lot of
lgbtq non-profits i really
feel like i have a deep connection to
the community even though i'm a straight
woman
just because it's so personal you know
they're my friends
and we're so close we're so tight
we run in a pack and
i mean they have so much love for me so
i feel uh a deep connection to them for
sure
yeah yeah it's a great north star
to get involved at an entrepreneurial
artistic spiritual level but also at a
political level
all these levels of involvement are
really important to not
just be a spectator but to be an active
player
yeah and you know i would do it it's not
necessarily a for me
i mean i'm always thinking of well how
can i create positive impact
you know and empower other people to
empower other people right
yes yes so i mean it's not necessarily
about money or fame or anything
i don't care for fame i mean i've i've
told you i've had people try to solicit
me to be on reality tv shows like it
doesn't necessarily mean i'm interested
or want to do it it's not about fame
um and it's not about money because i
can make more money doing other things
than being a mayor that's for sure i
just think that i could
you know really do some good when the
time is right
but i'm i'm also mindful that there's a
time and a place when i can make the
most impact
yep and it's not now yeah but later
definitely
yep yep yeah likewise with the goals
that i was
sharing with you about the presidency as
well yeah yeah
there's a time that's coming when there
will be
deep architectural change of our social
fabric that's
more geared towards the inclusive
stakeholding and other things that we're
talking about and i'm
yeah willing to step in so yeah we're
gonna it'll be fun
we're gonna have a lot of fun i know um
let's talk about super connecting
because you were just
you're giving me some stories obviously
both of us
are super connecting not only people but
ideas
and that you gave this really good
example that a lot of people don't think
about
um so you have these nodal clusters of
different connections
uh and with your higher level of
extroversion
and friendliness and sociability you
kind of have a
you have a propensity to gravitate
people towards you
that are looking to land in community
and feel at home
yeah i feel like i i get a lot of people
who reach out to me
when they feel like they lack a
connection
and now it doesn't necessarily mean
professional like yeah sure we all get
that right well some of us do where it's
like hey can you hook me up with like
this job or
you know who do you know at the said
company but i've noticed that
whenever there's you know within my
friend group if there's someone
who just moved to la from another state
usually they'll funnel them through me
because they know i have the network i'm
gonna be open to chatting with them it's
like and i wanna help
oh you're new here like how can i help
you build your community
yes and i'll connect them to the right
people so that they feel at home
because i think it's so important and i
know for a lot of people l.a can feel
very lonely
um just chatting with some friends i've
had
who are transplants here now luckily
i've never had that experience
you know i was born and raised socal i'm
from orange county it's like an hour
drive down south right in no traffic
so i've always had um a huge support
network
so i thought well okay so if
so if i have this massive support
network um
that's very diverse in
just all different types of people and
all different types of experiences it's
like
why would i not use that to help other
people who need it you know and it
becomes a win-win for everybody
i would probably say that that
this is one of the most important things
for
people to realize about as they become
more and more open to new people
open to connecting with
diverse across
fields that what happens is that you
become more and more of a
catalyst and a super highway in a funnel
for other people
that go through you as a point to get to
where they feel more like
they're at home and that that in itself
is reason enough to
to aim to strive more and more for
especially if your psychometrics align
with it if you're not hyper introverted
it and it does strive for that strive to
connect
with people across different fields
strive to connect with people across
different walks of life
strive to visualize your own network and
your own
sort of data so that you can know where
to go with the people that come through
you uh
and and be in service to that be in
service because like you said when the
person comes to you
you're thinking about being in service
to them so that they feel at home
that like that you know that in a sense
that's kind of what
evan had done a lot for me here same
yeah you know i think evan and i vice
versa with evan and i mean he's
connected me to people i've connected
him to people
and i think it's great because you know
i
i think for some people who don't do
that there's like a form of
possessiveness or jealousy
which i just think is silly or some type
of insecurity
but i want all my friends to be friends
with my other friends
if i know that they can potentially work
with each other
just or just have a good time or there's
something there right
and i also think it's very essential to
have a range of friends
in your life because i don't want all my
friends to be like me
at all because i need new blood to
cancel out the misinformation
that i do carry and have and my biases
and my blind spots
boom and i get that all the time with my
diverse friendships likewise
where i'll think i know something but
then they challenge that and i think you
know what
you have a good point do i disagree or
do i agree with it
depends but at least i know
where you're coming from and the other
perspective
i love that right that was so good that
was so eloquent yep
the blind spots that's it guess what
happens
when you when you get more and more of
uh openness to new
angles on issues
because they're coming from other people
because you've cared to be compassionate
and empathetic and want to undergo the
process of learning about what their
angle on it is
all of a sudden you become more and more
aware of your blind spots as long as
you're not
getting triggered and as long as you're
not egotistical
yeah that type of stuff you have to be
willing to be
go to go to it's really difficult to
restructure
your cognitive schemas because you're
constantly in a battle to
you know you're really wanting to hold
on to them and to those structures
yes and that's that cognitive dissonance
yes i have a professor who i became
friends with we're very tight and he'll
call me out on everything and anything
and he has
no issue doing that and i love that he
does that
you know because he comes from a good
place
yeah and i take what he says to her and
i have no issue with him doing that
because i can't have
yes jeanette people oh yeah around me
all the time amen
yes yes there's a lot of them out there
and i appreciate them
for different reasons but they can't all
be like that that's the psychometric of
agreeableness
and that you really want a good chunk of
disagreeability
uh because you want to be able to say
that hey uh you know i love you i
disagree but you know
that or or when it's a mentor that for
them to just blatantly just say that you
have a blind spot
right there and then yeah you're wrong
and here's why yeah yeah and then
that one's that was really interesting
i've i've really
yeah the mentors that have done that for
me have been
super influential mostly it's checking
my hubris
is mostly what it is i am i can i can
definitely
uh get very overly self-confident about
you know after i published high level
perception i had to had i had to have a
good dose of that in order for me to
you know realize that a lot of the a lot
of the hypotheses that i have
about the nature of consciousness and
reality are important but they're also
important to retain a deep level of
openness
continued openness and to not you know
be like i'm 28 and i know
you know right don't do that don't do
that
because you don't you don't know
think about all eight billion
perspectives and
all of their angles on what's going on
on the around the planet and
like the you know where we came from the
big bang where we're going
the godhead where gateway wherever we're
going like think about
all of the process of that's going on
inside of your body at a cellular
level everything that's happening in
math and physics and artificial
intelligence there's just so much
there's so much to even say there's so
much information
no one has enough time to be an expert
on it all
yeah hubris check the hubris yeah i'm so
happy that
that we talked about that's that's huge
i wonder what your take is
what is your take on the nature of
consciousness
my take on the nature of consciousness
um
i think that it's all about connection
that's what it is whether it's object
feelings person
thing and that
all leads back to the human ego
that's what i think it is at the end of
the day i think it's just
self but
you know a higher level of it means it's
not just about me it's about others too
but i think at a low level it's about
connection
which leads back to ego
that was a really interesting answer so
let's see so
when i was at mit two years ago i was
speaking with these phd mathematicians
and they were walking me through
how what else is there besides
relationships
and so that's the connections and that
it's super interesting because it's the
connections like you said between the
subjective and the objective
and it's also connections between the
subjective and their own
stories and emotions and feelings and
all this type of stuff
and it's connections between the
different neurons materially in the
brain
and there's all of these sorts of ways
to view
connections between these two nodes as
humans you and i
between two countries on the planet on
the macro level right there's so many
ways to view that
connections as a fundamental
piece of consciousness right or even
with an object
right a piece of artwork whatever yeah
yeah so yeah i mean it's a very
open-ended
interesting question it's hard to answer
that could be a whole thesis yeah that's
why
i took 10 months to aim to hit it
with my you know my thoughts and
perspective you know
and i would ask as a follow-up to that i
would ask
given the fact that you've lived here in
los angeles and given the fact that
you're at the point of synthesis between
entertainment and civic engagement what
do you specifically think
about my desire my
drive my north star in la about
trying to drive this question about what
is the nature of consciousness
and reality to the people with the
highest
influence and clout in the area what do
you think that
that style of reflective
processing for the people with the most
influence here will
catalyze well i think it's interesting
that you would ask that type of question
in l.a first of all because you know
it's kind of dense here like a lot of i
feel like
l.a is a culture of pr
it's pushing the next fragrance the next
tv show the next
book and it's very much low hanging
fruit
where it's just quickly clearly
succinctly
communicate it to said audience so that
they will pay
and consume and buy this or that right
or
move towards some action but i mean i'm
curious because i would love
to you know hear what people think about
that
i just feel like that's such a high
level question and to be honest with you
la doesn't value um
intellectualism like some other markets
in the u.s it doesn't mean that there
aren't intelligent people here
there definitely are there's a lot of
them they're just not as in the
spotlight if that makes sense
yeah yeah
it's about the optics that's la
it's about the optics and um not
necessarily so much about
the the amount of numbers in your bank
account i feel like that's maybe more
new york
or san fran it's more about the numbers
with your uh
social media following with your social
media impressions
i was having a conversation with a
really close friend of mine about
how social media has kind of
leveled the playing game because now you
can be in a room
with the wealthiest people with
millionaires and billionaires just be
and you could be you know living in like
a you know a 1500 dollar a month
apartment but just because you have the
social media cloud
you have the followership so now you're
in this room with all of these
millionaires and billionaires where you
know maybe like a decade ago
this would never happen yeah it enabled
mm-hmm
because i mean i know tons of people
with a lot of social media followers
who are struggling financially but they
look like they're popping
on instagram but they're not
they probably crashed on my couch at one
point yeah
so um i think it's really about the
optics here
um not everything is how it seems
it's really the narrative that people
put out there
and the type of image that they
manufacture
it's a lot of that for sure and i know
because i'm behind the scenes of these
things
yeah richard dawkins calls it the
extended phenotype
so we actually put out a
a biological signal via our
instagram yeah profile and
and when we interpret it that way it is
fascinating because
that's why it's at its absolute peak
you want to put only your absolute
peak into the social sphere because
you're using it as a mating tool
you're using it as a as a tool to
acquire more wealth and business and
friends
and you're using it also to
also create a a story about yourself
there's
there's it's a really interesting
way of perceiving that phenomenon that's
occurring and
you're also spot on that memetically
speaking
it might be more valuable uh
for somebody to have you know this would
be i would i would recommend
people to investigate into this
is it more powerful to have
let's say a billion dollars
or is it more powerful to have 10
million subscribers
on youtube it's a good question i think
that it
just depends on other factors right
that's a that's a pretty yeah if it
depends if you can take your billion and
transition it ethically into two and
three billion and then build a youtube
channel to get to 10 million after a
year
or whatever yeah for sure but i think i
think uh
it could be interesting yeah i mean you
could probably do a lot
with that but yeah so these are
interesting questions or what if it's
you know 100 million or 10 million
subscribers you know this these types of
questions are
it also depends whether or not you want
fame and whether you want to carry that
torch and do you want to be a mouthpiece
what can you communicate with that 10
million subscribers
what yeah what's your purpose what are
you trying what are you trying to do
yeah
and what's the strategy behind that
yes i really liked your answer
on connecting connections i like that to
consciousness i like that a lot
why do you think reality exists why do i
think reality exists
oh that's such a deep question why do i
think reality exists i think reality
exists because
so much of what we tell ourselves is not
real
and it's fake and i think so much is
made up
there's so much assumptions and so much
of how we see the world
isn't even real so because of that
there's reality
i'm so interested in your life that's
weird
in your line of thinking there like this
reality
that we're immersed in like you know
like fish in an
ocean yeah if you will
why does why does it exist and your
answer
is because it's not real because it's
not real
yeah okay and so tell us more what
do you what do you mean well because i
think of so much about how we
view the world ourselves other people
and
even our connection and our
consciousness to it isn't real
it's what we want to tell ourselves to
feel better
and to live and to wake up the next day
and to have like a sense of purpose or
whatever
i don't think it's necessarily real i
mean
okay i'm following your lineup so it
goes back down the ego
there it is i follow i'm following i'm
falling okay so because of that
the perception is not veritical the
perception
is something that we tell ourselves a
story to be
happier and healthier and more
meaningful every
every day and so it's that's the that's
this
is most real and and just the way people
are i think people are very magical
human beings with like
all sorts of crazy imaginations and just
wild stuff that goes on all the time to
the point where people don't even
realize it
so i think so much of our thoughts are
real you know
have you given the words
infinity or eternity much
contemplation uh i
can't say i have what are what are the
first things that come to mind when you
hear infinity or eternity
i think of uh space but i feel like
that's like the obvious answer
um but i don't know like i i think
infinity or eternally i just think of
something
influential that lasts forever it's like
something that just
transcends you know over time and then
it doesn't have to be physical is that
what we are
i think that well for me i think i'm a
moment in time
you know i think my energy will carry
but physically not really
and when you say your energy will carry
through
other people that's how it lives on
you know i mean i think that very
very little like a there's a very small
amount of people in this world who
actually make a big impact
but it doesn't mean that normal people
aren't impactful
right we need them to
and i think it's like a mosaic that
paints a bigger
beautiful photo but you know not
everyone is going to be like elon musk
yeah we're different colors kobe bryant
right and just who are just these
huge cultural impactful figures
but it doesn't mean that we don't have
value or that we're not important
there's that host saying what is it like
to the world you're only one person but
to one person you could be the world
right
and i think that matters yeah that's
great i love that one
it's a really good one yeah i think we
should rap on that that was such a good
one
oh so good yeah thank you
i don't know where it came from but i'm
glad i remembered yeah
to the world you're one person but to
one person you can be the world
that's hella good right isn't it so
poetic yeah
yeah so
yeah so that's just my two cents thanks
everybody
this episode was featuring
jeanette nguyen and her
incredible life journey thank you her
just getting started
yeah all of her north star goals exactly
fusing fusing
all things civic engagement with
entertainment and all things
entertainment with science hopefully and
entertainment with
tech and education and hopefully
consciousness art
yeah art i love art you know that's
important too yes
i love it that's what we're about yeah
there are some links in the bio below
for you guys there's uh jeanette's
linkedin profile also her instagram go
follow her go connect with her there
support the initiatives that jeannette
was talking about in the program
really think about that a lot you know
how can you blend entertainment with
civic engagement with science
with spiritual awakening consciousness
art all these different fields
and why is that important and how can
you get involved in that think about
that guys
think about that and go and build the
future manifest your dreams into the
world
architect that more beautiful future our
hearts know is possible
you can support us the links are in the
bio below if you believe in what we do
support us as well
and that is all folks let us know what
you think about
the episode in the comments below
i'd love to hear from you share it if it
made a profound impact on you
if it's your first time around hit that
subscribe button
like the video
what a fun convo jeannette nguyen thank
you thank you i had fun
that's so fun thanks alan so much more
to co-create on
right boom peace everyone bye everybody